[MUSIC PLAYING]
This episode of "Shots of Awe"
is brought to you by Norton.
So one of the next
big tech revolutions
that everybody is
talking about these days
is the notion of the
internet of things.
See, now that we are
extending intelligent sensors
into the world of everyday
objects, all of a sudden,
these objects are going
to be endowed with agency.
They're going to be
endowed with the ability
to give us feedback.
The world is going to become
intelligent and responsive
and going to
anticipate our needs.
The world is going to feel like
an extension of our mindedness.
"When everything becomes
linked with everything else,"
as Erik Davis used to say,
"matter becomes mind."
David Rose, in his new
book, "Enchanted Objects,"
essentially says that
we're moving back
into a world of animism, where
object's have actual agency.
They actually have a kind of
consciousness and that things
almost are enchanted,
almost are alive.
You walk into a
room, and the room
knows how you like the lighting.
And the song that you love
starts automatically playing.
And the curtains
automatically raise.
And the computer offers
you your favorite snack.
The full flourishing
of these technologies
promises to essentially
blur the distinction
between self and world.
The entire world
will have mind in it.
It's how the cognitive
philosophers David Chalmers
and Andy Clark used
to say, "we've always
been adept at dovetailing
our minds to work tools."
But when our tools
start talking back,
the loop will be finished.
We will have fully spread our
minds out into our universe.
This is the internet of things.
This is why it's a
game changer, and this
is why it absolutely
rattles my imagination.
So read up on it, right.
It's coming.